[Music]
I'm thinking you're with me you should
be like hey what's up my name's piggy
what's up sup brah yo is it go I've been
waiting for you pity let's go I'm
excited let's go I'm pumped I'm pumped
his bum oh it's raining pig ears I'm
pumped bum
I'm raining raining raining mm-hmm
mm-hmm
you thought it was a pig I'm rain I'm
rain [ __ ] whoa whoa what are you doing
it
why did you know that speaking through a
cylinder okay so who should we bring I
think we should call him
it's the final I come on it's Thai
family look at me I lost I am Stefano
what is this I don't
oh no nevermind I need Stefano seriously
though where's that it's not Stefano
wait this is ready what have you been
I've looked everywhere for you
what are you doing on top of a shelf I
don't know
where'd he go oh [ __ ] oh oh there is
he's in a really bad spot
it's the funnel ok carefully listen
carefully PD that monster is is blind
you can see you just don't make a noise
ok ok so funny I'll try o bucks if I
dolly a lot away guys
that's funny I was like oh [ __ ] I get
the feeling he sees me
no no no it's called he doesn't see you
it's a problem he's a mess where the
lever was I'm floating around cuz I'm a
dead pig mm-hmm
hmm I'm a snake I'm a snake you thought
I was pig I thought it was big
no I'm sneak look almost like all right
I think it was in here ye I'm a snake
I'm excited
ye ye snakes whoa did you see that
backflip holy [ __ ] that was what the
[ __ ] did oh please
this sound is freaking the hell out of
me
[Music]